FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Talks
at Mountain View.
We're excited today to be having
Anne-Marie Slaughter come,
with Kristen Gil moderating.
A little bit about Anne-Marie.
She's president and CEO of
New America, and the professor
emeritus at Princeton,
along with being
the former dean of the Woodrow
Wilson School of International
Affairs.
Most of us know her from
her "Atlantic" article, "Why
Women Still Can't Have It All."
And today she's come
in because she recently
published a book called
"Unfinished Business: Women,
Men, Work, Family."
And I think most
of us are pretty
familiar with Kristen Gil.
She's our vice president
of business operations,
and she's the former head
emeritus of woman at Google.
So welcome, both.
KRISTEN GIL: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE].
Welcome, Anne-Marie.
I think I speak
for a lot of people
when I say we are so excited
to host you here today.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Thank you.
KRISTEN GIL: Congratulations
on your new book.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Thank you.
I still like to see
it, kind of pat it.
KRISTEN GIL: Exactly.
So I thought we could
start, actually,
by taking you back to when
you wrote the article "Why
Women Still Can't Have It All."
Could you tell us a little
bit about the personal story
of what was going on when
you decided to write that?
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Yes.
So I'm thrilled to be here.
And, yes.
I'm trying to go back.
So while I was working
in the State Department,
I was-- my husband
and my two sons,
who were 10 and 12 when I left--
or no, 8 and 10 when I left.
I would leave first
thing Monday morning,
and I would come back
very late Friday night.
So I really saw my kids
only two days a week.
And from the
beginning, it was hard,
but I didn't expect it
was going to be easy.
But it was harder than I
expected, because I'd always
traveled a lot.
So I was always gone a lot.
And in the book, I actually say
that my youngest son drew me
as a laptop once
when he was drawing.
He was asked to draw his family.
And he didn't-- not a woman
at a laptop, a laptop.
And then he drew
my husband cooking,
because my husband is the cook.
And he drew his brother.
So it wasn't like
I had ever been--
I was never completely focused
on raising them, anything
but-- but it was
much harder than I
expected to be gone that much.
So all the way through,
I really was like, wow,
I'm getting tugged in
ways I never expected.
And I had never felt
guilty about working.
I'd always had the view that
I'm a much better mother
because I work, because I'm
passionate about my work.
That makes me happy.
That makes me a better parent.
But this was tough.
And as my 10-year-old
turned into a 12-year-old,
he was middle school.
And middle school was
rocky, as it often is.
And I started
getting calls where,
OK, so he's getting bad grades.
Well, that's not
such a big deal.
Well, he's skipping class.
Well, you know.
By the time he got
suspended from school,
that was a different thing.
And he's in public school.
So this was not-- it wasn't
like he was in a private school
and we put him in public school.
This was really an issue.
And so that's when
I started realizing,
wow, I'm not going to
be able to do this.
I really do have to go
home, and I am not in a job
that I can do from home.
You cannot be an Assistant
Secretary of State from
Princeton, New Jersey.
You just can't.
It's like the world
does not wait on you.
Got to be there.
So I sort of played
with this idea of, wow--
and I said, as I
said in the article,
that I told a friend-- I've
told women all my life,
women can have it all.
You can make it happen.
And, wow, I really can't.
So then I go home, and I was
more focused on being home
and, as I say in the book,
cooking massive breakfasts
for my sons every morning.
I'd get up at 6:00 every
morning and make fresh muffins
or fresh hash browns.
And finally my kids are
like, enough already.
It's fine.
And then I sat down-- well,
a couple things happened.
One was I really noticed
that when I told people
that I'd left government
after two years
because my tenure was
up-- in other words,
you get a two-year
public service leave,
so if you stay another
year, you no longer
have a lifetime position.
That was fine.
Everybody gets that.
You don't want to give
up a tenured position
at a great university.
When I told people
I had come home
because we had two teenagers
who for the last four years
they were going to be at
home, or the last six years,
I got a completely
different reaction.
I got essentially
the reaction that
told me very quickly
the person I was talking
to was revaluing me downward.
They were thinking, she's not
the player I thought she was.
And that just wasn't true.
My reaction was, no, I
am doing what I consider
to be the right thing to do.
Partly, my kid needed me.
But equally, I'm doing
what I want to do,
which is to be there
while they're home.
And they won't be home forever.
And why on earth am I
getting judged this way?
And that's when
I really thought,
OK, I have been not only telling
people they could have it
all if they just
tried hard enough,
I have also been
part of the women who
have made those judgments.
And now I'm on the
other side, and I think
it's important to speak out.
Now, I never anticipated
that the article I wrote
would have the
impact it did, but I
did feel like I've
had a great career.
I'm high enough up
that if I say this,
it will have more of an
impact than if I'd been home
all the time or if my career
was around women's issues.
KRISTEN GIL: Yeah.
So, if you can then,
tell us a little bit
about-- in your book, you
talk about half truths.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Yep.
KRISTEN GIL: So I want to
actually get into to your point
about, why is it that people
judged you as stepping back?
And I want to get into
that a little bit,
but first I think we should
lay the foundation for what
you talk about are the
half truths out there.
You list, if you commit enough
to your career, which you just
said, if you marry
the right person,
and also if you
planned your career--
ANNE MARIE SLAUGHTER:
Sequence it right, yeah.
KRISTEN GIL: Yeah, if you
sequence everything right
from child rearing, et cetera.
Can you talk about why
those are half truths?
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Yes.
So the first one is the
lean-in proposition.
The first one is, if you go hard
enough, you can make it work.
And I will say, and let
me just start by saying--
and I say in the book-- I
have enormous respect for what
Sheryl Sandberg has done.
I have personally
been on the other side
of women asking for raises
because they've read the book.
And I say in the book that
when that happens-- of course,
as a feminist, I'm thrilled.
As a boss, you know, I
don't always say yes,
but I respect the
person for asking.
So I say in the book, when
that happens I smile and I
tip my hat to Sheryl Sandberg.
And I really feel that strongly.
So this is not either
or, regardless of
what the media may say.
And I go out of my
way to say how much I
respect what she's doing.
But it's one piece
of a larger puzzle.
Because it is what I
always told people,
but I hit a tipping point.
And there is nobody more
committed to their career
than I am.
My family would
have said, no way.
If she had the chance to
be promoted in the State
Department and go higher-- there
are only a few jobs above me,
like Deputy Secretary of State,
Under Secretary of State.
They're all good jobs.
And nobody would
have thought that I
would have made a
different choice,
but I hit a tipping point.
I just hit a point at
which it couldn't happen.
And so the reason I say
it's a half truth-- it's
really important to go hard.
All the stuff in lean in
is right, but many of us--
and I was super privileged.
I had everything else
going for me-- do hit
an unanticipated tipping point.
You can have a child
with special needs.
You can get divorced.
You can move away,
if you're depending
on your extended family.
You can have a teenager who
turns into an alien, even
more than most teenagers.
So my point is, when that
happens, it's not your fault.
And it's not because
you're not ambitious.
It's because life happens.
And so that's why I
say it's a half truth.
And the same is true
with who you marry.
It's incredibly important.
Sheryl's right.
That's a really
important choice.
But I had a lead-parent husband.
I had a husband who was
there, and still, our kids
needed both of us, hands on.
And he's my second husband.
I love him.
He's my final husband.
Let me say it here.
But I didn't expect to get
divorced the first time.
Nobody expects to get
divorced when you get married.
But we didn't have kids
when I got divorced,
but if we had-- you can't
just always make that choice,
and even when you choose
a great husband, or wife,
and whether a man or a
woman, again, things happen.
And finally, the sequencing--
this should be a whole truth.
It should be the
old thing that says,
you can have it all but
not all at the same time.
And that's what
lots of people say.
And I say, that's terrific
and ought to be true,
because we ought to
be able to make room
for care and for going hard.
And you should be able to
be considered for leadership
positions whenever you're
ready as long as the work is
good enough.
In fact, lots and lots and lots
of women who have stepped out,
or work part time, or
work from home when
they have caregiving
obligations, or men, actually
can't get back in.
Or they can get back
in, but they're never
going to be in the same
place that they were.
So there again,
it's true in theory,
and it's true for some
women, but for many and many,
it's not.
KRISTEN GIL: I think
that's so true,
and what I love is I think
you have some great policy
ideas on how to
solve some of those.
But if we could,
I'd like to hear,
because you also talk
about, a bit of the way
it is today is you either
lean in, or you get out,
or you're pushed out.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Or
you're shut out, yeah.
KRISTEN GIL: But you also
talk about this vision of,
we should be able to lean
in and lean back a bit,
and think about our careers.
What I love is you take the
long view of the career.
We should think about our
careers as a portfolio.
Can you talk a little
bit about that vision?
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER:
Yeah, absolutely.
So there's two metaphors in the
book that I use for careers,
and the first is absolutely
that we think about our careers
like interval training.
So if you're an athlete, you
know, if you go really hard,
then you slow down.
You don't go hard all the time.
You'll burn out.
You'll injure yourself.
The whole point is to
give yourself rest,
and then you go hard again.
And that's how I've thought
about my own career.
I've changed jobs roughly
every five to seven years.
And there have been periods
where I've gone all out,
and there have been areas
where I'm always working,
but I'm more focused on having
kids, on being with my kids,
or on other things that
I want to do in my life.
This isn't just about kids.
It's about other
things you want to do.
So I suggest you think
about your career
as a series of
intervals, some of which
you're really going
to go all out.
And that may be
when you're young
and you don't have
caregiving obligations.
That may be at a period when
your kids, actually, you either
have a spouse is going
to be a lead parent,
or your kids are just
in a really good place
and you can do it.
But you think about that
over your lifetime, which
it actually means you're
going to have much more time
for other stuff you want to do.
A lot of you are going to
live to your 80s, 90s, older,
out here, the end of
death and all that.
But we won't go there.
Let's assume we haven't
gotten to the end of death.
We still do have
long lives, and you
don't want to achieve everything
by the time you're 60.
What are you going to do?
You sit around for 30 years.
This is not an
attractive proposition.
And your kids are
only young once,
and your parents
are only old once.
So why not take that
time to enjoy it and live
that period of life
to your fullest
and then have time
to go hard again?
And the second is, I
think about careers
as a portfolio of
skills and experiences.
So let's say you
wanted to be me.
You'd look at not
the title I hold--
I've had many different titles.
But you'd look and you'd
say, well, I speak, I write,
I manage, I strategize,
I fund-raise.
There's a whole
portfolio of skills,
and I've worked in
the private-- well,
not really the private
sector, but the public sector
government, universities,
and now the nonprofit sector.
And really running New America
is like being an entrepreneur
but just in a nonprofit world
rather than a for-profit world.
You can get those
skills and experiences
many different ways.
You can step out of
where you are now
and run an NGO for
two or three years
while you want to have more
time and be your own boss,
and learn how to fund-raise
and learn how to be a speaker.
You can go back to school.
You can try your
hand at writing.
So if you think about it as
intervals and a whole portfolio
of skills and experiences, you
can actually equip yourself
for the bigger jobs later
in life without thinking,
I have to follow a prescribed
set of progressions.
KRISTEN GIL: And I was able to
recently-- you were actually
speaking at the
Computer History Museum,
and I heard you talk
about some of the skills
that you learn as a parent being
quite applicable to actually
being a leader and a manager.
ANNE MARIE SLAUGHTER:
Absolutely.
KRISTEN GIL: In fact,
comparing some of the trainings
that you had.
One was around
parenting, and one was
around new manager training.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Exactly.
Exactly.
The thing that I absolutely
did not believe three years ago
that I now believe
is that the skills
of caregiving help you grow and
develop as much as competition
does.
And I actually got this
from a male philosopher
who wrote a book called
"On Caring" in the '70s.
He's a man.
He was a father.
And he talks about what
caring does for you.
And it's entirely
written in a male voice.
This has nothing to do
with work and family.
It's not a
rationalization of time
spent parenting is going
to be good for your career.
It was talking about
what investing in others
teaches you.
So when we compete, we
invest in ourselves.
We get education.
We work really long hours.
We acquire a set of skills.
But when we invest in
others, we actually
enable them to grow and to
achieve their full potential.
And to do that, it's a
combination of, you shape them,
you guide them,
you support them.
But you also let them go and let
them make their own mistakes.
Because if you don't,
they won't grow.
You have to let them
make their own mistakes.
Well, that description
I could give
to you in countless
management manuals.
There's tons of--
empower your team.
Particularly now, where
you can't plan everything.
You support your team,
empower your team.
Let them reach their
full potential.
That is the definition
of parenting.
Good parenting is, you teach
your kids a lot of stuff.
You guide them.
You support them.
You're there when
they have problems.
But if you're a good parent,
you do not do for them.
You let them make
their own mistakes.
Otherwise, they don't grow.
And so, that process--
and it's hard.
It's really hard.
And none of us have a
manual as to how to parent.
We generally look at
how we were parented,
or sometimes we look at how
we were parented and say,
we don't want to do that.
We'll do something else.
My husband read tons of books.
I figured I'd figured it out.
But those skills are completely
transferable to being a manager
and to being a
leader, so much so
that I would look for people
with caregiving experience
as managers.
Because I think it
forces you to do this
in a very immediate context.
KRISTEN GIL: We
have something here
at Google, where we really value
in our leaders people who have
an adaptive leadership style.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER:
That's the other one, yes.
KRISTEN GIL: They know how to
adapt based on the situation
or based on the
needs of the people
that they're working with.
Somebody needs more help
here, needs more runway there.
Really, what a
tougher place, where
you're having to
adapt year after year.
I always talk about how I hit
these moments with my kids
where suddenly I screw up
because I was absolutely
not expecting that they could
do something now they can do.
But that's a whole other story.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: But
no, that's-- adaptability
to changing rhythms is
definitely another thing that
caregiver teaches you.
KRISTEN GIL: That's right.
But let's follow
this thread on care,
because I think
what's so insightful
is that you note
that, as a society,
we undervalue care,
to the extent it's not
counted in our GDP.
In the fields that are
generally caring fields
and often have
traditionally more women,
significantly more women
than men-- eds and meds,
you call it-- education
and the medical field,
particularly nursing.
Can you talk a little
bit about the fact
that we undervalue
care and what you
think we should be doing
about that to change that?
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: So
this was the great revelation
of the book that I
started it by saying,
this is a women's issue.
And then I kept looking at, we
have too few women at the top,
but we also have far too
many women at the bottom.
I call it an unlovely symmetry.
So too few at the top.
Enormously, the poorest
members of our society
are women-- the majority of
minimum-wage workers, the shift
workers.
And why?
Because they're exactly the
people who are trying to be
breadwinners and
caregivers together,
and we're not
supporting their care.
So that was one piece of it.
And the middle part,
in the middle class,
you are looking at all
the caring professions.
Which, if you're a
doctor, that's different.
Although, even there,
general practitioners,
who are the doctors who
do the most caring of you,
rather than the slicing of
you or the very specialized
reading of charts, et cetera--
the more the profession
involves care,
the less well paid
it is and the less valued it is.
So nurses, teachers,
obviously-- we
do not value teaching in
this country, and it shows.
When Finland went
from a terrible record
as an educational system
to the best in Europe,
what did they do?
They made teachers' colleges
look like the Ivy League
so that the best people
wanted to be teachers.
It's not that hard to do.
We value technologists, we get
great people as technologists.
So I really then started
thinking about this.
Well, wait a minute.
We don't value the
caring professions.
We don't value care.
If you're somebody at the top
and you take time out for care,
you have a really hard time
getting taken seriously again
and getting back in.
And if you're at the bottom,
you get no support for care.
So you could say,
well, that's just
because this was women's work.
Men were always ahead
of women, and men
did competitive things and
women did nurturing things.
So we devalue it that way.
I think it's deeper than that.
I think part of it is American.
Other societies value
caring for their elders--
let's start with that-- which
we don't value very much at all,
much more than we do.
And many other societies
with extended families
value the taking care of the
parents and the children,
and the children
and the parents.
So I think there's some of that.
I think we are a deeply
competitive society.
And I should just say,
if my brothers were here
or my husband were here,
I'm really competitive.
I don't like to lose.
And I play tennis every weekend,
and it's ritual humiliation
because my husband
beats me so badly.
But I do think there's
something in our society
and the kind of embrace of work.
And again, I love to work.
But I call it the
competitive mystique.
We're sports fanatics, and
that's all about competition.
And so I think there's
something more to it
than that it was women's work,
but I think as a society,
we are really suffering
from not valuing care.
Take education as
the best example,
but also for middle-class
jobs, those eds and meds.
Those are fast-growing sectors,
but those are not sectors
that we value and pay well.
But if we want a
strong middle class,
we have to value them
and pay them well,
and we have to have men in them.
You've got a chronic
shortage of nurses,
but male nurses still face
a lot of discrimination,
even though in the military
men have been nurses forever.
We call them core men.
We don't call them nurses.
OK, so let's change the term.
But obviously, men can
take care of other men.
They've been doing it forever.
So I do think we need to
break open this conversation
about, what is it that we're
all about investing in ourselves
and we don't value the
people who invest in others?
KRISTEN GIL: So you
mentioned, for example,
what Finland did to try to
change the talent that they
were attracting and the
value that the society was
putting on teachers.
Do you think that something
like that would work here?
Do you have other policy
ideas around this space
to change this?
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Yeah.
I do.
Actually, for education, it's
easy to say and hard to do.
New America does a ton
of work in education.
And what you've
got to do then is
you've got to take on
the teachers' colleges.
And the accreditation
of teachers' colleges
is not so easy.
But we could start
by valuing teaching.
So one of the things
I say in the book
is that I've stopped
asking people,
what do you do, as the first
thing that I ask anybody.
I actually try to ask them,
have you read a good book?
Have you seen a good movie?
Something that implies that
there is something to life
beyond work and that
you can actually
be a multidimensional person,
not a unidimensional person.
And I do think when people say
they're a teacher-- I actually
cite this.
I think she's from one
of the Nordic countries.
She may be Finnish.
And she describes coming here.
In Finland when she
says, I'm a teacher,
people treat her
with real respect.
Here, if you say
you're a teacher,
people look over your shoulder
and find somebody else
to talk to.
It is not a valued profession.
So we can, in fact, change that.
And I think Teach for America
has helped change that.
Top schools, a lot
of competition.
But the deeper
questions are, we have
to see this as a social
and economic issue.
And I say that the one
place that really gets this
is the military.
The military has
on-site daycare.
They pay early
education teachers.
That means the people who are
taking care of babies, one-,
two-, and three-year-olds-- they
pay them the same as they pay
high school teachers, based on
education levels and experience
levels.
And they understand that if we
do not invest in our children--
and we now know, and many
of you probably know,
the neuroscience shows
that you're not just
teaching kids stuff for
those first five years.
You are shaping
that child's brain.
You are determining
how much that child
can learn for the rest
of his or her life.
And there's plenty of empirical
studies on what happens
to children who get good
care and get the right kind
of stimulation versus
kids who don't.
You're baking in
the achievement gap.
You're baking in inequality by
not valuing those first five
years.
So if we think of it as
a national security issue
and as a competitiveness
issue, how on earth
are we going to
compete if we are not
taking those jobs seriously?
And I had my kids in
daycare at three months,
and I thought they got
better care than my husband
and I would give them.
But alternatively, I now
think about it and think,
maybe I could have
taken a couple years
where I worked part
time, because, boy, I
know I'd be investing
more even than the best
daycare in my child.
I'd be taking them to
all sorts of things.
And now I look and I think, if
I'd known then what I know now,
I might have actually
retooled that.
So I think that's the way
we've got to talk about it,
because it is not
a women's issue.
KRISTEN GIL: Yeah.
I think that's exactly right.
In fact, when I think about
some of the policies--
I'll try to pivot us now
to what companies can do.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Sure.
KRISTEN GIL: Let's think
a little bit about Google.
But one of things
I'll share with you,
which you may know
already, but we recently
instituted parental leave that
was the same for men and women.
ANNE MARIE SLAUGHTER:
Yep, which is great.
KRISTEN GIL: Now, there
are some differences
for women for the medical
leave portion of actually
physically delivering the
baby, but after that it's
exactly the same.
And it's quite generous
by American standards,
certainly not by European
standards, but very generous.
And I remember when
I heard about this,
and it was touted as
extending paternity leave, so
that it was parental leave.
And I thought, well, this
is the biggest win for women
everywhere, because it
isn't a women's issue.
And what we are as a society
assuming at the very beginning
by having the notion
of maternity leave
and not a paternity leave is
that the primary caregiving
responsibilities are the
responsibility of the mom.
So maybe we should come back
to what companies can do,
but in that vein, I'd actually
like to hear a little bit more
of your personal stories
around your husband
and how he has taken that
lead-parent role, as you
both call it.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: So we
started out as co-parents,
and we were in
paradise for parents.
Ivy League universities, wealthy
universities, are very liberal.
And just as we started
having children,
they started equal paternity
and maternity leave.
On top of that, you
teach in a semester.
So I had one child in October
and the other in January.
You don't teach for
that whole semester,
because that's the way it works.
So we each got a semester.
And we also had daycare.
But it meant that one of us
was in charge for the first six
months and the second
six months of our son's
life for both kids.
And what that meant was
we were really equal.
And as I said, Andy
read all the books.
He knew a lot of the research.
I was more kind
of, figure it out.
But we were equally
competent parents.
And there's no question.
He could get Edward to sleep
just as well as I could.
Even with breastfeeding,
still, the guy can do a lot.
And we actually mixed it up
with breastfeeding and bottles.
That was enormously important.
So from the beginning,
we were co-parents.
And then I became a dean.
And Andy, at that point,
started doing more.
As he wrote, I got a job that
required me to travel more
and to be on other
people's schedules.
So he was already the flexible
parent, but I was still there.
I worked only about
a half a mile away
and I was still there.
Although I would get
treated as a war criminal
when I showed up always late
for parent-teacher conferences.
And Andy would always be there.
And he would be what
I called the halo dad.
We're doing the same
thing, but he gets the halo
because he's the dad and I
get, why aren't you hear?
Like, what's the
matter with you?
But then I went into
government, and of course, he
was completely raising them.
He was there five days a week.
I was only there on weekends.
I came home, and
then ironically,
because of the article,
I got invitations
to go all over the
country to speak.
So I felt like I should go
in with hypocrite in chief.
Here I am.
Yes, I am in California.
And yes, I left the
State Department
to be home with my kids.
And believe me, they know
how to push those buttons.
They would tease me.
But Andy, at that
point, became what
we describe as lead parent.
And what it means is, really,
the parent who may be working
may be working full time.
If you're flexible,
you can do that.
But it's the parent who's there
when the unexpected happens.
Because that is
what caregiving is.
It is constantly dealing
with the unexpected.
The unexpected getting sick.
And when they start in daycare,
they're just sick all the time.
The unexpected is some
problem at school,
some problem they have as
teenagers, where they really
need you to be there
to talk it out.
The field trips, just all these
things that happen-- somebody
has to be available.
And that somebody cannot be
somebody who always has to be
on a plane, or somebody who
has to beat deadlines where
there's just no give in them.
So he has been the lead parent.
And he wrote this
article in the Atlantic
called "Why I Put My
Wife's Career First."
But what he says,
and this is what
I think men really don't
get, or should get more,
is what he's gotten out of it.
On the one hand, when our
second son goes to college,
he is going to go full
throttle on his career again.
But he would say, he has this
extraordinary relationship
with them, much deeper than
his father had with him.
Because in the end,
investing that much time,
even when you're
yelling at your kids
and forcing them to do
things they don't want to do,
they do grow up
and they gradually
appreciate the
fact that you were
willing to make them do that.
And when we travel,
they text him.
They know Dad's
going to be there.
And then I text them back and
say, what's the matter with me,
and why didn't you text me?
I'm very competitive.
But the way I think
about it is men
are really missing
out, that this is one
of the great things about life.
It's meaning and purpose, and
you're investing in your kid.
And it's not always fun,
but it's totally worth it.
And men at the end of
their lives look back,
and their first top
regret is, I didn't
live the life I wanted
to lead but the life
that people expected me to lead.
And the second is, I
didn't spend enough time
with my family.
KRISTEN GIL: That's right.
Can you talk just a
little bit, though,
about how the either
half truth or myth,
or whatever you want
to call it, of how,
but it's the mother's job?
And you make a good point
about how we actually
have to step back a little bit
and let them play their part.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Yes.
So a couple of the
other half truths
that I try to explode, one
is, a child needs its mother,
which you hear all the time.
And I say, my taxi driver
used to say it to me.
And he meant it as a compliment.
He meant it as, mothers
are just fabulous.
I, of course, as I'm
heading to Washington,
do not necessarily hear
it as a compliment.
But my point was, woah,
you can't get to equality
if you think a child
needs its mother more
than it needs its father.
And my view is children
need adults who love them.
Ideally, two
mothers two fathers,
one mother, one father.
Preferably a whole
constructed family.
We have lots of
people who we consider
to be like uncles
and aunts, who are
friends and former students.
And so that's one.
And the other is, a
man's job is to provide.
It's biblical.
It's in the Koran, as well.
But who says that's
providing cash?
Why can't that be
providing care?
Because I provide both, and
my husband provides both.
And why shouldn't we
think about it that way?
But here's the kicker.
So this is a book that I
expect women will probably
pick up first.
Even the most
enlightened man, this
is probably not the first
book he is going to go to.
I hope that the women
will read it and hand it
to the men in their
lives, very much so.
But when the men
read it, there's
this one chapter
they'll hand back
to the women in their lives,
because there's a chapter that
talks about female sexism.
And it says,
essentially, most of us
think that we really
know how to do-- we
women-- know what we're
doing at home much
more than the guy does.
And I say that if you
walked into your office
and a guy said to you, I'm
biologically better at this,
but I think you can do it
if I micromanage you enough,
you would sue him.
But that is the way many of
us-- and I'll include myself
until my husband just
put his foot down--
that's the way we treat our
husbands or our partners,
because we really don't
think they can do it.
And when I give this speech,
in lots of audiences,
people laugh, as you all just
laughed, but then somebody
raises their hand and says, but,
come on, he really can't do it.
And I'm like, no, no, no.
What you're saying is he's
going to do it differently
than you do.
And the example I
use is my husband
thought it would be a great
idea for our kids to watch
all the Marx Brothers movies.
He thought this was part of
their cultural education.
And so for I don't
know how many weekends,
they watched all the mark
Marx Brothers movies.
And he thought it was
critical to teach them
poker and every other
game known to man.
And I wouldn't have done
any of those things.
On the other hand, let's just
say his tolerance for clutter
vastly exceeds mine.
His notion of what they
should eat is not always mine.
Although he is a much
better cook than I am.
He has different views.
And essentially, he
finally said to me, look,
I'm going to run this
household my way.
If you want to do it your way,
you can come home and do it.
But if I'm doing it, you're not
going to tell me how to do it.
And at that point
I realized that I
thought that I knew
what to do because I
was raised by my mother, and
she was raised by her mother.
But the flip side is business
was always done by men,
and most women I know do not
think that's automatically
the right way to do it.
We think we know
how to do it, too,
and we think our way
is sometimes better.
So if we're really going to do
this, women have got to let go
and women have really got to
examine our own, not even so
subconscious, bias.
I think a lot of times
it's conscious bias.
KRISTEN GIL: It's true.
It's societally programed.
As you were talking, it
made me-- the first instance
that I really
recall understanding
that my husband was going to
be super involved with our kids
was when I was pregnant.
So I hadn't even had
the first child yet.
And I was starting to figure out
the decorations for the baby's
room.
And he actually was, like, can
I actually have a say in this?
And it never occurred to
me that he would want to.
I actually thought I was taking
a burden off of his plate
and that I would just do this.
And I got to tell you,
that was the beginning
of many, many instances
where I realized
he wanted to be an active
and very involved parent.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: That
can create some friction.
KRISTEN GIL: It definitely can.
We were sharing stories
earlier about our husbands are
a bit more of the
disciplinarians in the family,
and we're perhaps
more the soft ones.
Now, I want to get
back to companies
and what companies could do
to foster better policies.
But there's a great
quote from your book
where you talk about reading
a company's flexible work
programs reminded you of reading
the constitution of an iron
curtain country that boast
all kinds of liberties that
are really just for show you.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: Yeah.
Yes, that's one
of the few places
I could get my foreign policy
background into the book.
There are not a lot of
references to foreign policy.
But exactly.
Because I grew up in the Cold
War, and I was a law professor.
And all these former
communist countries
had every right under the sun
on the books, and none of them
were practiced.
And what you see in many
companies are liberal policies,
but if you take advantage of
them, you are stigmatized.
And that is not
real flexibility.
That is not real work life
accommodation in any way.
That is saying, here
it is, and anybody
who doesn't want to be a player
can take advantage of it.
So that means when women
do, they are stigmatized,
and most men don't, for the same
reason, because then they're
knocked out.
So really doing this is not
just having these policies.
It's having senior
people, women and men,
take them, and really emphasize
that this is important.
And I'll give you an example
from New America where
I do this.
It's not maternity
or paternity leave,
although we have equal
maternity and paternity leave.
But we have six weeks
of paid time off a year,
and you can use it for whatever.
You can extend your
a family leave.
You can use it on
whatever you want.
You can go around the world.
I don't care.
But what I care
about is you only
get two weeks of
that that rolls over.
So four weeks so that, if
you don't take that vacation,
you lose it.
So you cannot just roll over
balances and cash it out.
Because I think you will
be far better at your job
if you take four
weeks off a year.
And I walk that walk.
I take four to six
weeks off a year.
I take four weeks in the summer.
I take two weeks
certainly in the holidays.
And I will take long
weekends frequently,
because I'm a very
creative person
and I've read all the
literature on creativity.
And I know that if
you recharge your mind
and expose yourself to different
sites, stimuli of all kinds,
you will be more creative.
You will be better at your job.
But if I just put those
six weeks out there
and didn't do it myself,
nobody's going to believe that.
They're going to follow what
is modeled, not what is said.
What are the real rules?
So if you're really
going to do this,
you've got to have men,
as well as women, who say,
yep, I'm taking my
leave, and this is great,
and I'm bonding with
my kid, and I expect
everybody else to do the same.